[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le
journal de l'afrique sur france 24 à la
une ce soir le continent africain
particulièrement touchée par l'explosion
des cas de rougeole une hausse de 400 %
sur les trois premiers mois de l'année
selon l'organisation mondiale de la
santé en cause la vaccination des
enfants qui a pris du retard à cause de
la pandémie de kobe 19 nous serons dans
ce journal avec geneviève bec payant
responsable santé de l'unicef en
république démocratique du congo
des centaines de nigérians de retour
chez eux au nord-ouest du nigeria malgré
l'insécurité persistante il avait fui
les violences jihadistes et trouvé
refuge au niger voisin à niamey on
retrouvera un rôle de girard notre
correspondante et puis nous irons en
afrique du sud où après deux ans de
pandémie vous verrez qu'une vente un peu
particulière sous forme de haine ftd
oeuvre numérique dématérialisé a permis
de sauver le musée de johannesburg
reportage à suivre
mais avant de développer ses citrons va
partir en guinée les anciens présidents
de l'assemblée nationale et de la
commission électorale ont été inculpés
la nuit dernière notamment pour
corruption et écroués à la prison civile
de conakry conakry on retrouve malik et
diakité notre correspondant
les derniers à être placé sous mandat
d'arrêt dans la nuit de mercredi à jeudi
ce sont ahmad damaro camara président de
la dernière assemblée nationale sous
alpha condé et le scénic amara ancien
président de la commission électorale
nationale indépendante ils sont tous
deux poursuivis pour des faits présumés
de détournement de deniers publics
enrichissement illicite et blanchiment
de capitaux ces deux membres influents
du rpg le rassemblement du peuple de
guinée d'alpha condé ont d'abord été
entendus plusieurs fois ces dernières
semaines par la direction centrale des
investigations judiciaires de la
gendarmerie nationale avant d'être
envoyé mes crédits devant la krief co2
re pression des infractions économiques
et financières à leurs avocats dénoncent
une justice instrumentalisée la demande
de mise en liberté provisoire qu'ils
avaient émis a été rejeté par la justice
il rejoindra en prison plusieurs hauts
responsables du régime dessus dont
l'ex-premier ministre ibrahima kassory
fofana
on en vient à cette recrudescence des
cas de rougeole sur le continent selon
l'organisation mondiale de la santé ils
ont augmenté de 400% sur les trois
premiers mois de l'année par rapport à
la même période l'année dernière l' oms
mais aussi l'unicef tire la sonnette
d'alarmé nous sommes avec geneviève bec
couillon responsable santé l'unicef en
république démocratique du congo jeune
jeff beck cognant bonsoir merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur france 24
de janvier à mars
17500 cas de cette maladie virale très
contagieuse ont été répertoriés selon le
m s comment expliquer ce regain
épidémique s'est liée avant tout à la
pandémie de kovy 19
la pandémie 2019 est certainement à
l'origine de de ce qu'on appelle des
goulots d'étranglement par rapport à la
vaccination les mamans ont certainement
eu très peur d'amener leurs enfants et
de d'éventuellement se contaminer dans
les centres de santé donc après
plusieurs mois et beaucoup de
communication pour leur dire non
revenait les vaccins sont là les vaccins
de routine contre la rougeole qui est
une maladie qui tue contre la polio qui
peut handicaper votre enfant les vaccins
contre le bcg tous ces vaccins sont là
mais malheureusement les mamans sont ne
sont pas revenus aussi rapidement donc
nous avons déjà malheureusement au congo
depuis le début de l'année sur 26
provinces 23 provinces ont déjà reporté
des cas on a quarante et un mille cas de
rougeole depuis le début de l'année on
est presqu'à au même montant que toute
l'année dernière et donc avec l'unicef
neurones nous renforçons les efforts du
ministère de la santé pour contrôler ces
épidémies là où elles ont lieu dans les
zones de santé les les infirmiers
congolais savent vacciner les mamans
savent où aller mais malheureusement il
faut vraiment y aller très très vite et
contrôler l'épidémie de rougeole la
situation n'est pas la même partout
quels sont les pays où la flambée des
cas est la plus significative
vous vous êtes en république
démocratique du congo là aussi la
situation n'est pas la même vous l'avez
évoqué partout sur le territoire
bien sûr de province en province ça
change par exemple tout le long des lacs
de lac kivu du lac tanganika
actuellement nous avons des cas de
choléra vous comme vous avez peut-être
entendu deux cas de défaut la ont été
répertoriés dans une province de bornes
dakar nous avons vraiment actuellement
des campagnes qui sont préparés pour
contrôler la polio pour aussi vacciner
contre la fièvre jaune et tout ça ce
sont des calendriers de ce qu'on appelle
la vaccination de routine qui doit avoir
lieu pour prévenir contre ces maladies
malheureusement on a pris du retard et
pendant ce temps-là l'épidémie de kovy
dwi est venue elle est venue moindre
peut-être dans un grand pays comme le
congo et mais malheureusement elle a
vraiment eu un impact négatif sur les
services de santé de routine en
république démocratique du congo vous
l'avez évoqué on est ce qu'on assiste à
une recrudescence de l'épidémie d'ebola
à bandes dacca au nord-ouest du pays
deux personnes sont mortes en depuis fin
avril l'organisation mondiale de la
santé a mis en garde contre sa possible
propagation
quelles sont concrètement les risques
je voudrais vous dire que déjà à bamba k
non seulement l'équipe du ministère de
la santé mais les équipes de l'unicef et
de l'om s'était déjà présentes nous
avons très rapidement
déployé plus de 20 tonnes de matériel
pour limiter la contamination pour
désinfecter nous équipes sur le terrain
ont mobilisé les communautés à
rechercher des contacts est allé à les
inciter à aller se faire vacciner la
vaccination a déjà commencé
déjà depuis trois jours et nous équipes
de l'unicef a pu aussi au niveau
psychosocial toutes ces familles qui
sont vraiment très ébranlé des
différents foyers
afin de rechercher les cas contacts de
vacciner d'appuyer au niveau
psychosocial aussi les éducateurs dans
l'est dans les écoles afin que chacun et
les moyens de prévention donc ce n'est
pas la première épidémie malheureusement
au congo des mollahs et nous avons les
gestes barrières et avec les ailes avec
les populations et le ministère de la
santé très vite il est beau les bonnes
actions ont eu lieu et nous espérons
vraiment contrôler pour le moment on n'a
que deux cas on espère vraiment de
contrôler le plus vite possible merci
beaucoup geneviève bécaud ayant d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir sur sur france 24
la guerre de communication se poursuit
entre paris et bamako l'armée française
a qualifiées de douteuses les
accusations du gouvernement malien mardi
il évoqué des tentatives de subversion
une violation de l'espace aérien malien
par la france tout ça fait suite aux
révélations la semaine dernière par
l'armée française d' images filmées par
un de ces drones ces images montrées
souvenez-vous la mise en scène par des
mercenaires russes de wagner présumé
d'un charnier autour de la base de
gossip base du centre du mali que la
force barkan venait de rétrocéder à
l'armée malienne l'armée française en
tout cas réfute toutes les accusations
d'espionnage et répond avoir respecté à
la lettre un accord de mars 2013 la
france qui par ailleurs réagi de manière
officielle à la coupure définitive
mercredi du rfi radio france
internationale et france 24 au mali le
quai d'orsay a fait part de sa vive
préoccupation et appelle bamako à
reconsidérer sa décision
vous en parlez dans les titres il avait
fui chez les violences djihadistes au
nord ouest du nigeria plus de 4000
nigérian réfugié au niger voisin sont de
retour chez eux retour encouragée par
les autorités locales malgré
l'insécurité et des services quasi
inexistant dans la région à niamey les
précisions de notre correspondant à un
rôle de girard
plus de 500 familles nigérianes ont
quitté le niger ces derniers mois pour
regagner leur région d'origine suite à
l'appel du gouverneur de l'état de borno
frontalier du niger à lui souhaite que
ces populations retourne de leur côté de
la frontière comme dans le reste de
l'état la ville de madame fattori a
accueilli environ un mois des candidats
au retour et même si depuis aucune
attaque d'envergure n'a eu lieu dans la
ville les risques restent très élevés
boko haram et l'état islamique en
afrique de l'ouest continuent de
contrôler des territoires voisins de la
ville ce retour des populations
nigériennes au nigeria eh bien il était
censé s'opérer dans le cadre d'un accord
tripartite entre le niger le nigeria et
le haut commissariat aux réfugiés
il n'en est rien puisque ce retour a
effectivement déjà commencé hors de tout
cadre légal et cet accord lui n'a pas
encore été mis en place ça peut
contribuer à des retours qui seront pas
pérenne au bout du compte c'est ça le
problème donc des gens sont susceptibles
de revenir à nouveau au niger ce n'est
pas une bonne chose parce qu'on a ce
moment on encourage l'espèce de deux
systèmes ou de dynamique de mouvement
pendulaire et c'est parce qu'on sait pas
ce qu'on veut il est mieux que les
réfugiés on attende que les conditions
soient là et qu'on le fasse dans un
cadre justement ainsi finalement accordé
et
ce qui pas qui va te permettre de donner
une pérennité à ses retours ça que les
gens rentrent et une fois qu'ils
rentrent ils sont iront dans des
conditions qui de sûreté de dignité et
il ya une assistance qui veut redonner
il ya il ya des conditions de sécurité
qui va permettre de retourner à leurs
activités ce niveau là une activité
agricole
car l'objectif affiché de cette
initiative du nigeria c'est d'inciter
les populations expatriées de force mais
aussi les déplacés internes à retourner
travailler dans leurs champs al'approche
de la saison des pluies une initiative
est une manoeuvre pour le moins risqué
et depuis 2009 et l'insurrection
djihadiste dans le nord-est du nigeria
quarante mille personnes ont perdu la
vie et plus de deux millions de
personnes ont été forcées à se déplacer
hors de la zone en tunisie l approche de
l'aïd la fin du ramadan pas de ruée dans
les magasins de vêtements cette année à
cause des crises à répétition l'afld
l'inflation atteint en effet des sommets
une hausse des prix est accentuée par la
guerre en ukraine à tunis on retrouve
lilia blaise
dans le centre ville de tunis les
courses de l'aïd vont de bon train mais
beaucoup de tunisiens que nous avons
rencontré confine pas forcément acheter
des habits neufs notamment dans les
grands magasins à cause de
l'augmentation des prix du prêt-à-porter
entre 15 et 20% qui correspond aussi à
l'augmentation de l'inflation un pays
qui est aujourd'hui à 7 2%
je vais aller ailleurs peut-être que je
trouverai quelque chose de moins cher
les prix sont très élevés par rapport au
passé c'est pas tout est plus cher c'est
pas seulement les vêtements mars
faute de moyens suffisants beaucoup de
tunisiens se tourner vers des produits
issus du commerce informel et de la
contrebande que vous pouvez voir tout
autour de moi qui sont vendus par des
marchands ambulants en centre ville de
tunis ou bien la fripe dernière option
dans les souks et voilà ici j'ai trouvé
une paire de chaussures que j'ai acheté
pour 70 dinars pour trois enfants si je
dépense 70 dinars par paire si on ajoute
les vêtements cela coûtera au minimum
500 dinars vous vous imaginez la somme
la fripe offrent un meilleur rapport
qualité prix vous pouvez trouver la même
chose dans les magasins mais ici c'est
moins cher avec un salaire peu élevé
rien est accessible en grande surface
donc je préfère la fripe même s'il y en
a pour tous les budgets grâce aux fripes
aujourd'hui les courses de laïcs pèse
énormément sur les budgets des tunisiens
c'est plus de 300 mille familles
nécessiteuses qui vont bénéficier d'une
aide de l'état comme à chaque aïd elle
tourne autour de 60 dinars soit 18 euros
et pour finir on va partir en afrique du
sud alors que là bas les musées ont
beaucoup souffert de la pandémie de
coheed 19 une injection de fonds très
particulière a permis de sauver un musée
celui de johannesburg une version nfc
c'est à dire numérique d'un mandat
d'arrêt contre nelson mandela a permis
de récolter plus de 200000 euros la
vente d'oeuvres d'art sous cette forme
utilise la même technologie que les
crypto monnaie comme le bitcoin c'est un
reportage signé caroline dumay notre
correspondante au coeur de la ville du
cap une petite société s'est imposé sur
le marché mondial des mft les jetons
dont fongible elle a vendu l'image en
trois dimensions du mandat d'arrêt de
nelson mandela en 1961
cette image est associée à un code
unique sur internet
c'est un certificat d'authenticité dans
le monde digital
si vous achetez le dard elle viendra
avec un certificat d'authenticité
tu trouveras d'où elle vient quelle est
son histoire
sa provenance ce certificat digital
n'est pas interchangeable
il est stocké dans un grand livre de
données numériques un corruption ces
singes tendons sont gilles
le jeton domfront ship du mandat d'arrêt
demandé là c'est vendu à 113 1000 euros
ces fonds permettront de rénover ce
musée à johannesbourg qui est fermé
depuis deux ans dans les années 60 cette
ferme servait de quartier général sucré
aux responsables de l' insee nelson
mandela s'il est caché
c'est un hommage à ses camarades que ce
fils de militants à créer ce musée mais
il a rapidement rentrer d'argent alors
quand on l'a approché pour soulever des
fonds sur internet il a tout de suite
accepté you est bon tout cela permet de
créer des répliques qui moyon de la
valeur
génère des revenus
alors qu'en fait vous ne vous
débarrassez pas vraiment des
grands jours le mandat d'arrêt originale
n'a jamais été vendus il fait partie des
trésors de ce musée est maintenant que
les fonds ont été soulevées les membres
du conseil d'administration ont hâte de
commencer les rénovations on va tout
nettoyer on va faire couper l'herbe
payer les arbres et laisser la voix de
lilieslief revenir résonner aux oreilles
des sud africains afin de préserver
notre héritage historique le musée de
lilieslief réouvrira ses portes au
public dès que possible
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal de
l'afrique merci beaucoup de l'avoir
suivi rester avec nous sur france 24
alain formation continue
[Musique]
et refi et france24 présente
le café des sports votre émission 100%
football si tous les vendredis débat
passionné échanges sans concession pour
une analyse complète de l'actualité
sportive de la semaine
et le café des sports à vivre en direct
sur rfi est à voir sur france 24